de la famille monsieur le ministre la
parole est un monsieur nicolas dhuicq
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
monsieur le garde des sceaux devant des
élèves de l'école nationale
d'administration pénitentiaire sans
prévenir la préfète du département sans
prévenir le président du conseil général
une hauteur sans prévenir le député la
circonscription sans prévenir le
président de la communauté de communes
sans prévenir les maires vous avez
annoncé la fermeture brutale de la
centrale de clairvaux
monsieur le ministre clairvaux c'est
plus qu'une centrale c'est tout un
symbole c'est toute l'histoire
l'administration pénitentiaire monsieur
le ministre à clairvaux depuis des
générations
ce sont les surveillants de
l'administration pénitentiaire grand
professionnel qui travaille qui
appliquent le comme neuf pas d'autres
centrales tout le règlement
d'administration pénitentiaire et rien
que le règlement de la ministre à sion
pénitentiaire monsieur le ministre
au moment où tout le monde parle du
terrorisme et de l'islamisme radical en
prison financés par les pétrodollars ici
présents dans l'hémicycle
monsieur le ministre en ce moment à
clairvaux même un imam un rabbin et un
curé travaillent ensemble pour donner
une image ouverte de la religion
monsieur le ministre
clairvaux c'est un bassin d'emploi qui
concerne tout le département du lot tout
le département de la haute marne
monsieur le ministre dans un bassin
d'emploi rural allez-vous tant de mépris
pour la ruralité
avez-vous tant de mépris pour des gens
qui travaillent allez vous tendez mépris
pour des mandats l'illustration
pénitentiaire fonctionnaires qui
travaillent chaque jour pour la sécurité
du pays
monsieur le ministre la fermeture de
clairvaux c'est un crime devant la
nation c'est une atteinte à la sécurité
de la nation tous les prisonniers les
plus dangereux sont passés à clairvaux
tous les jeunes y est les plus
difficiles à gérer surpasser à clairvaux
pourquoi voulez-vous fermer une centrale
qui n'est pas vécue
contrairement aux dénégations que vous
faites oui il ya nécessité en construire
une prison à lavau une maison d'arrêt
mais de grâce ne fermait pas la seule
centrale de france qu'il fonctionne car
vous aurez devant vous tous les
surveillants l'administration
pénitentiaire qui ont déjà su
merci la parole et à monsieur jean
jacques urvoas garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice monsieur le député la
dureté de votre question veut sans doute
traduire les inquiétudes des personnels
de cet établissement
c'est donc à ces interrogations que je
vais répondre
la fermeture de cet établissement la
décision de fermeture n'est ni une
foucade ni un acte irréfléchi ce procès
pèse d'un travail qui a été conduit
depuis plus de dix ans par
l'administration pénitentiaire
au regard des difficultés que cumule cet
établissement parce que c'est bien là le
problème particulier de clairvaux ce
n'est pas tant la place particulière
qu'occupe cet établissement dans la
mémoire pénitentiaire que chacun
reconnaît ni la qualité des personnels
qui sert mais simplement le fait qu à
clairvaux nous accumulons les
difficultés
c'est le coeur du problème je comprends
monsieur le dpp l'émotion des personnels
j'entends les alertes des élus je veux
dire à ceux qui s'inquiètent aujourd'hui
que je ne prends pas cette situation à
la légère vous étiez hier à clairvaux
vous y avez rencontré mes plus proches
collaborateurs qui ont passé la journée
le directeur adjoint de l'administration
pénitentiaire était là au regard des
éléments qu'ils ont appris qu'ils dont
ils ont eu connaissance j'ai demandé un
supplément d'information
évidemment je suis prêt à tous les
dialogues je recevrai les organisations
syndicales qui pourraient le demander
mais permettez moi simplement de vous
poser une question pourquoi en
sommes-nous arrivés là parce que ce
bâtiment dont vous connaissez l'histoire
n'a pas été entretenu pendant des
décennies que l'on n'a pas investi que
les conditions de travail des personnels
se sont dégradées que les conditions de
détention ne sont pas acceptables
donc c'est cette incurie qui me conduit
aujourd'hui à agir
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux